your capacity
to be offended
is not something that anyone
need or should respect
in you
you were calling for twitter to shut
down trump's account and were happy that
it happened yeah that's a very different
position to pretty much everybody else
why did you take that position trump
university as a story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop in my view
that's just a conspiracy that's a
left-wing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to donald trump absolutely it
was absolutely but i think it was
warranted but sam you can't do that sam
you've got to be fair
most people
in our society
even if they're nominally religious
really are struggling to to find meaning
in in their day-to-day but when you look
at just the the hour by hour increments
at which you know life has doled out to
us you're cast out of deep sleep or you
know the phantasmagoria of dreams you
know when the alarm goes off in the
morning
and
how do you feel about your life and what
is going to give you
moral urgency and meaning
millions and millions of people found it
at specific moments in our you know
recent history like george floyd
killing was certainly one of those
moments where it's like okay enough is
enough this is my religion
[Music]
did you know that you can ask guests
your questions that's right when you
join our locals community not only will
you know who we're about to interview
you have the opportunity to ask them
your questions you have the chance to
ask jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norco
simon evans larry elder david badill
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein inaudible
dr david nutt jimmy dore gad sad blair
white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford
i see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge
metaphorically speaking not just because
they're american our locals gives you
access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry on the road from
the usa i'm francis foster i'm
constantine kissing and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with fascinating people delighted to say
our brilliant guest today is a
neuroscientist philosopher and one of
america's and the world's most prominent
public intellectual sam harris welcome
to trigonometry thanks guys yeah great
to be here it is great to have you on
the show uh we mentioned that usually
when we start the show we ask our guests
to introduce themselves you're well
known enough that you don't need to do
that but what we did want to talk to you
about which is what we've been asking a
lot of our guests on this trip in the
u.s is how are you who you are
because you've done things that most
people wouldn't do or wouldn't want to
do would be scared to do calling out
some ideologies that people are afraid
to call out
that takes courage but it also takes
determination it takes something why do
you have that something how did you get
it
it's a hard question to answer i mean i
think
there's uh one algorithm i'm running
more than most uh which is
you know what i would call intellectual
honesty right and and so you're the
burden is not to be
who you were yesterday the burden isn't
to join some tribe who who you know
you'll get social
uh reinforcement from for you know
conforming to
um
so it's
in so far as i'm continually just trying
to figure out what's true
and what's consistent with what i
claimed was true five minutes ago or
five years ago
uh
that causes me to just
bump up against
taboos and and blasphemies and
ideologies that that um
are more rigid than that right i mean if
you're if it really it's it's
i mean even having an identity itself is
too much you know it's like you not only
can you not really conform to a tribe
you can't really even conform
to who you were yesterday
if your
your master value is to be honest and
rigorous and available to new data and
new arguments and and
uh new insights that's a very good
answer but doesn't answer my question
which is how did you become that way why
are you there yeah i have no idea i just
might like that was my
you know factory setting and so from a
very early age
uh
you know i i guess i showed up as a
a skeptic on many fronts or i was
certainly an argumentative
teenager you know
yeah so
um so yeah i mean that was that was
really uh
some kind of default and uh that part
really hasn't changed but i think i pick
my battles better now than i used to i
could use you know i could turn any
dinner party into a knock down drag out
debate about the most fundamental issues
uh anyone could summon and you know i
think i
um
as i get older i pick my battles more
um
just because i like that the hassle
factor
of touching certain topics in certain
ways has has become more salient for me
i mean twitter was that was the real
teaching tool for me like i i just you
know i i got on the platform as everyone
did
not really aware that i was enrolling
myself into a psychological experiment
to which no one had consented and and
the the outcome is as yet unforeseen
and
um
yeah i just kind of
let loose
you know with on
various topics and i would you know when
i would see some malefactor there who
was treating me or other people badly
well then i had to deal with that right
then and there and and
um
yeah it's just
the hassle factor
of dealing with the
the toxicity of it and all also just the
the um
i'm convinced now that at bottom it's a
misrepresentation of humanity right it
doesn't seem like i'm you're actually
dealing with what someone wrote there i
mean it's not it's not in error
but you're not getting the whole person
you're getting a
a um
a part of them that has been amplified
by the
the frame into which the conversation
has been put and the frame has certain
features that are
not helpful to good conversation it's
got anonymity it's got you know it's got
facelessness it's got
um the performative aspect you're doing
it in front of your crowd or some
possible crowd
uh so it just it you know it's
disastrous for intellectual honesty and
and
um
compassion and
uh
you know theory of mind under actually
understand taking the time
the extra moment to understand where the
other person is coming from and so it's
you know there's no principle of charity
so it's just it's really a disastrous
machine for uh
manufacturing discord
we had a guest on the show called
richard grannon who made the point that
what it does is reduces everyone to an
avatar
so if everyone's in avatar what does it
matter if you attack them if you
you know dehumanize them if you
misrepresent them because the game is to
win right it's not to actually have a
discussion is to destroy and ultimately
to win
yeah well especially if you're not
if you're a public person dealing with
people who are not public people right
because then there's really this then
it's just a single shot
you know lottery it's not a
there's no
ongoing future of collaboration or
cooperation that is being maintained
i mean it's even bad when you have two
public people who
you know are who know both know they're
gonna
meet each other in real life at some
point still the the wheels come off
rather often to a surprising degree but
um
yeah it's just uh
yeah
in the end i think it's bad technology
which is still somewhat inscrutable
because it seems like it should be good
i mean and in some ways it is good
because you're seeing
you know you're seeing a lot of smart
people
tell you what that most
interests them and most worries them on
a daily basis and you know sending you
articles and and videos that you and
that's that's why that's why i can't
break my connection to it because i'm
following so many smart people who are
curating for me an information diet that
i still appreciate
um and then i you know occasionally put
my own stuff out there just so it's like
a kind of a marketing channel but i'm
doing much less
in the weeds back and forth with even
public people who
i notice uh you know you know poke me on
on a given issue or whatever so
sam
does it not go do you not have a little
thought in your head when
you go to tackle these very contentious
subjects you know and you know that
you're gonna get pushed back you know
that you're gonna get flat you know that
you're gonna get misrepresented
do you not think i really shouldn't be
doing this or
what goes through your mind before you
go out and you make your point
well again i i uh
i think about it more than i used to now
i mean i used to i used to do it very
there was basically there was no
friction in the system i mean i just was
like okay this is like that
that cartoon meme you know somebody on
the internet is wrong about something
you know
i was that guy on twitter and um
so i'm not that guy anymore and i really
do
pick my moments and
there's a cost to that because there's
you know that you're you decide to sit
certain
moment you know cultural moments and you
sit on the sidelines and
um
but
i mean if i guess if i could just
distill it to a to a lesson here it's
like a you're not
you don't you don't always need to have
an opinion about everything right you
certainly don't always need to have a
strong opinion about everything and even
if you do have a strong opinion
you don't always have to be the person
expressing that opinion because
very likely someone else will right and
you know given you know given those
adjustments to the
to the machine
you you can
just decide you know is this do i really
want to spend the next
24 hours dealing with the aftermath of
this thing that i'm tempted to tweet
right or to say in some other format and
in particular it it relates to
the likelihood that certain
personalities are going to go berserk
and with certain people it's it's you
know it's guaranteed that they're going
to go berserk so like do i yeah here's
this
this this odious
uh opinion expressed by a you know a
semi-odious person
who really deserves to hear what i think
right now
is it worth you know
whacking that hornet's nest and then
just dealing with
dealing with and being seen to deal with
or to or to not deal with and to maybe
look like you can't deal with the
aftermath right it's like
sam you talked about tribalism at the
beginning and that's something that
francis and i both feel very strongly
is contributing to much of the
divisiveness and the the way things are
going and look let's be clear you know
the show is called trigonometry we want
to explore difficult subjects there's no
question that neither him or i awoke in
the in the consent opposing that
ideology has been a big part of what we
do but the tribalism is is a different
thing we don't want to be in the
anti-work tribe or yeah tribe right
and there was a tribe
around 2015 2016 that's a very small
tribe of very smart people
which was referred to as the
intellectual dark web
which i remember at that time we weren't
doing this we're just two comedians i
remember watching you guys have those
conversations and being inspired by
people i don't think you guys had the
answers but you had the right questions
you did have the right questions
and then over time we watched that loose
tribe of very bright people as loose
tribes of very bright people always do
crumble disintegrate fall out yeah what
happened
well the first thing that happened is
that it was actually
for some of us more than others a
tongue-in-cheek
label for a tribe that really wasn't i
mean
none of us are tribal people you know it
really is a herding cats sort of
situation
and
when i lost so you know it was eric
weinstein coinage which i launched on a
podcast we did
and
i think in that context i i telegraphed
that i thought it was tongue-in-cheek i
mean i think he probably thought it was
more inearness than i did or he was at
least more attached to the
label
um
and then very quickly there were people
who sort of joined this this collection
uh or who were said to be in it who some
of whom i had never heard of at that
point
who
you know upon just a little bit of
analysis
revealed themselves to be people who i
you know i really don't agree with not
not just on the actual substance of
specific opinions just
just their methodology by which they
would generate opinions or their lack of
methodology um so
you know i'm not inclined to name names
but they're people who like
it just it's just wrong to think
you know
they were ever moving in the same lane i
was in at that point when we were all
called idw people right
um
but i think the biggest force of
fragmentation was
trump and what
certain people did or didn't do with
that phenomenon you know and this is
what i was going to ask you i'd say
there were two things that fractured it
from that looking i mean
later but
trump was the so let's start with trump
because i want to talk about covert as
well but if we start with trump
you took a different view to almost
everybody i would say in what was
described as idw in the sense that you
were
uh i think you were calling for twitter
to shut down trump's account and were
happy that it happened yeah that's a
very different position to pretty much
everybody else why did you take that
position
well for two reasons one so that
the non
uh
the generic reason is
and this is something i've never gotten
a clear answer on for many of the people
who took the different side of this um
and many so many of these people are
ostensibly libertarians or at least you
know quasi libertarians and they they
want
something like a minimum
of state coercion and and control
they don't want just a proliferation of
laws
you know just to to make our lives more
difficult
um and that's a that's an orientation
you know though i'm i consider myself
liberal
and have always voted as a democrat i
mean until until we
dealt with this woke apocalypse you know
i i would have certainly called myself a
democrat without much self-consciousness
um
i you know i've always had this
libertarian
uh kind of underpinning to my my
politics which is
you know
if the private sector can handle it it's
probably best done there right i mean
just given the level of inefficiency and
and
poorly aligned incentives you get in a
government bureaucracy
uh and
peaceful honest people should be should
have the right to be left alone you know
so it's like unless somebody is
harming people or um
you know guilty of fraud you know the
i.e theft for you know
stealing from people
we don't need the government involved
and um
so you know
that's my general framework and many
people
ostensibly in in this group ostensibly
agreed with that um
so when i look at twitter
you know twitter is a company
that
can decide to you know i mean as someone
who has started you know
information-based companies at this
point i'm just thinking about what is
what's the scenario under which i would
want the government to force me
to have alex jones on my podcast or have
donald trump on my podcast should i be
able to have anyone i want on my podcast
is it conceivable
that my podcast could grow so big or
that my you know that any other platform
you know i've considered creating a
social media platform right
if that could grow so big that suddenly
the government would have an interest in
forcing me
to have people on it
who for whatever reason i object to
having on i mean so this is this is some
this is a way in which i'm
i'm more extreme than than most people
on the left like i i do think at this
point
in history
you should be able to have a social
media platform
and exclude any specific group you want
and just say that's the way we do it
right and if you don't like it boycott
us right so like i i wouldn't have said
this in 1964 when we're when we have to
pass a civil rights act
but at this point i think you should
have the right
to be
an [ __ ] who destroys your reputation
and and suffers the
the penalties in you know in the
marketplace of ideas right
so i think if you want to just have a
social media network for beautiful
people right or people who are you know
guys who are over six feet two and
blonde hair and blue eyes right you know
i can't get on
you should feel free to you know raise
money for that enterprise
launch it and i'll be you know i'll
laugh when it fails right so like that's
now
under some construal that kind of thing
you know is or should be illegal you
know if you're if you're just a normal
person on the left but
uh i don't think i think at this moment
in history it shouldn't be but in any
case i just when i look at twitter i see
a company
that
has a term has terms of service which
people like alex jones and trump clearly
violated i mean whether they in fact
violated
this terms of service as written
i think they violated any
coherent terms of service that twitter
should have had right like you you
shouldn't
knowingly be able to turn your mob
on a private citizen
and ruin their life
lives through doxing right which is what
jones and trump were doing it just again
and again and again to people every time
i mean
jones was doing it with the sandy hook
parents right you literally have this
time you're conflating two very
different people i mean alex jones does
not belong in this conversation i'm not
interested in that no no but i would
dispute that i think trump is
essentially we got alex jones as
president of the united states i don't
think they're very different people i
think it's the same phenomenon
in my world because just the level of of
misinformation disinformation lying
the charlatanism the the the conscious
fraudulence of everything at scale
and the targeting of individuals
with with known consequences right like
like trump every time trump singles out
a specific
citizen
and says look at this jackass who's you
know trying to you know whatever
whatever
the claim would be
that is a human sacrifice we know that
person's life is just never the same
again because he's turned
tens of millions of morons on that
person
and you know vicious morons on that i
mean like that's the the core
of the trump phenomenon
is now and has been for many years i
mean really since the beginning
since he you know certainly since he
became the front-runner and certainly
since he became elected in 2016
it's a personality cult i mean it has
all the dynamics of a personality cult
these are not reasoning yes there are
some there are a few calculated people
like peter thiel on the margins who have
some story as to why they would back him
right but the core of the cult you know
which is all you know nested with
queuing on and and
and uh conspiracy thinking and the big
lie and
you know it's like trump can do no wrong
right he's um
that is so it's yeah i mean as a venn
diagram it's just it overlaps
80 without the alex jones phenomena so i
just i see them as the same problem i
see these these are
these are
you know if they're not actually
clinical clinically you know diagnosable
as psychopaths they're the next best
thing these are people who
are so
malignantly selfish
and so careless with respect to the
consequences of their actions in the
lives of others that if you if you are
right if you own a platform or you're
you know you're
overseeing a publicly a public company
that owns a platform
why should the government force you to
keep these people on right like you
should be free to say sorry you're not
on my watch are you going to be having
these consequences yeah and with trump
it was after january 6 that was just
that's when it happened i i thought it
happened a year too late but i mean
january 6 finally convinced dorsey he
should kick trump off and that i mean if
that's not going to convince you that
you know we have we had a at that point
we had a sitting president
who for months and months and months i
mean
at least six or eight months you know
certainly months prior to the november
election
would not commit to a peaceful transfer
of power
and then he did
you know certainly something
whether it was everything in his power
or just a lot
he managed to see that we did not have a
peaceful transfer of power right and
then
you know so who's what's gonna what's
the mob going to do on january 7th and
8th and 9th you know if you just leave
trump
on the platform i thought i mean i just
thought it was a
very simple decision to kick them off
and and
it it
totally analogous to the alex jones
decision i mean alex jones is just less
consequential but
i mean there are sandy hook parents who
have had to move 10 times since their
kids were murdered
that's all on alex jones right and it's
and it's all conscious it's uh it's all
he could see the consequences of his
actions in real time it's not like he
woke up after you know five years and
thought oh my god i can't believe
that you know it was totally inadvertent
i released a podcast and you know then
it had this totally unforeseeable
consequence in the lives of
the these grieving parents no no he
monetized
their misery
with just a blizzard of lies
alex jones is a for me a different case
but
i think trump i mean trump is just i
hear what you say
in your mind they're similar he got the
reputation washing of having
successfully become president
you know he's alex jones okay yeah uh
francis before you you move us into
covet let me try from a different angle
sam because i want to explore this
intellectual point right
do you really want to live in a country
where
you have a digital public square which
in my opinion twitter is we can disagree
about that if you want but that's my
opinion it's a digital public square and
you have a company that has clearly
one-sided enforcement i i hear what
you're saying about delegitimizing the
electoral process that trump did right
and i was concerned about that i think
you can't question the system in that
way
but when you see that he gets
banned and then a story about hunter
biden gets banned
that under the guise of it being russian
disinformation we later learn it wasn't
russian disinformation that's a lot of
people seems like you know i said when
we were talking to joe rogan it's
putting your hand on the scales
in favor of one side
in the digital public square you add
that to the banning of trump and
lots of other people being banned from
one side predominantly right is that
is that the world you want to live in
where one team gets to just ban people
it disagrees with off the platform it
gets to pretend that things that are
true are not true it gets to shut down
the sharing of information with people
who want to make their own democratic
choice
well it's a hard question and they're
pieces of the question that are
individually hard it's like the hunter
biden laptop story is something that i
still
don't have a
full
opinion about i actually don't know what
we should have done about that i mean so
i see the reason i see both sides of it
i can argue either side of it that the
so let's leave that piece aside
the bias on the platform so so either
twitter is a company
that can do what it wants right it can
have its own terms of service it can
change its policies it can
you can change you know it can decide to
you know it can have a point of view or
not right
or
we have to seize it as some kind of
you know crucial piece of public
infrastructure
that has to to you don't think that it
is a crucial piece of public
infrastructure i think i think people
who are addicted to twitter feel it is
right
most you know and i think it's you know
i don't think it should should be um
and it's it's odd to say that it's just
so it's first of all it's just i mean
facebook is much much much bigger right
it's just that we have a lot of smart
people journalists
uh brands uh political people focus
concentrated on twitter so twitter moves
the the conversation more than facebook
does but it's it's it's the scale of it
is much smaller um
i don't know i just feel like
people can start their own companies
which they have right they can start
competitors at twitter there are many
people who you know twitter is not it's
still a failing business right it's like
it's not
it doesn't work really i mean facebook
is is a much better business
um
there's nothing stopping facebook from
becoming
stickier for intellectuals and
journalists and that's
attracting more of the conversation over
there
um
i don't know it's just it's an extreme
move to say
you
you can't
you can't be biased
right like who's who's going to say that
but behind behind the scene of that
is a law in the end
and there and therefore it's a gun
therefore it's it's jail time for the
person who wants to keep breaking the
law right so like just imagine imagine
if twitter the twitter board is like
what you
everyone gets what they want you know
everyone who's who's of this opinion
gets what they want you just we're gonna
we're gonna come in
and and enforce something like um
a zero bias state in twitter in so far
as that's possible
and if the if the employees and the
board just say you know sorry we have a
point of view we want we want to
have we don't like these people and we
like these people
um
what does now you just break up the
company you just say
you know i mean i i thought what i
thought it should have happened with
twitter is i thought
jack dorsey should have deleted it i
mean i literally thought he should have
got the nobel peace prize
deleted it right
um
but
uh
yeah i don't so in any case
should there should they be forced to be
impartial
i'm very skeptical
of that should they be cajoled by
unhappy people like yourselves or like
you know the
um
the trump fans to um to behave
yeah i mean i think so yeah yes i think
if they were going to be
the first thing to admit is it may be
impossible to do this impeccably right
it's like it's like
until we have
you know perfect artificial intelligence
it's just going to be impossible to be
truly consistent with your terms of
service because
you're always going to be able to find
the example of the thing that was not
appropriately moderated yes but if we
all know that if that laptop was donald
trump's junior oh yeah this would be
true that's that's all i'm asking oh
yeah well so but that's so let's take
that piece um
i think it was totally appropriate
to view trump
in a
to be existing in a in a
domain that was orthogonal to partisan
politics i my criticism of trump is
totally nonpartisan right there is
absolute there's literally nothing
i say about trump that i could say about
any other republican right and i think
liz cheney is a total hero right so so
and i don't agree with her politics at
all right like liz cheney is a
religious maniac by my lights right and
in in that sense
kind of a terrifying political figure
like like that like the the old me who
you know was just worried about the
christian theocracy in the united states
um would have just
revolted at everything she would attempt
to implement as a politician
but
at this moment she's you know she has no
bigger fan than me
because of how she's dealing with the
trump phenomenon the trump phenomenon is
not a matter of political partisanship
he is a he's just a swede generous uh
phenomenon and it's
again it's it's it's analogous to having
elected alex jones president united
states it's it's a it's a com
it's not a matter of his po like i
probably agree with half of his policies
or more than half of his policies it's
not a matter of policy it's a matter of
having someone who's totally unfit
to have power be given more power than
any person in a generation
and
he's unfit for
in every possible way it's like it's not
it's not that he's just got a few screws
loose like every screw is loose every
screw that you would want
totally cranked down
is loose or non-existent in him
um and so yeah so it's
but that's my argument so like so so my
argument is that it was appropriate for
twitter
and the heads of big tech and journal
and the heads of journalistic
organizations
to feel that they were in the presence
of
something like a a once in a lifetime
moral emergency right whereas this is
not the same thing as not liking george
bush
you know or not liking john mccain or
not like in mitt romney for their
politics
this was
here's a guy who
is
capable of anything
right he's not he's not ideological
but he's again he's a black hole of
selfishness right he's he's he's just so
there's no telling what he's going to do
um
and we cannot afford to have four more
years with this guy right and and so
um
so what what should
well-intentioned people do who have a
lot of power in these various ways you
know you're running the new york times
you're running cnn you're running
twitter
what should they
conspired to do
admit that it's those conditions
admit that trump is their fault
from the left absolutely that that's
well don't know that that's the perverse
thing it's totally their fault he i mean
cnn cnn gave us trump right well no
before cnn gave us trump mark burnett
gave us trump i mean there's if there's
one person
who could have
not done what he did and and it could
have closed the door to this whole
phenomenon it was mark burnett
um
but
yeah no by giving him the attention you
know but he was he was great ratings you
know for a year for the whole run-up to
to the 2016 election
oh yeah no there no one has clean hands
here but at the 11th hour when it's when
who knows how this election is going to
go
who know who knows what the capacity for
you know disinformation at the last
minute to to tip the balance
is
then what do you do with the hunter
biden laptop story
when we already know we we know how this
played out in 2016 with the hillary
clinton email you know press conference
where comey and in in
an abundance of scrupulosity he felt
like he had to come before the cameras i
think ten days out from the election and
say
you know we've we're going to open up
this this investigation again because
we've got anthony weiner's laptop
uh
we could see i mean again her failure to
become president was over determined she
was an appallingly bad candidate
um
but
in terms of just tracking the poll
numbers you could like that was that was
the killing
blow to her candidacy right that that
final moment and this was a this was a
highly analogous situation this was
we're going to open up this laptop from
hell
and the news cycle for who knows how
long
is going to be just
just
[Music]
conceivably just a nuclear bomb of an
october october surprise
and we're going to get four more years
of trump if we actually give this a fair
hearing but sam but you can't do that
sam surely you've got to realize that
you've got to be fair and number the
thing that i want to do we're all equal
before the law yeah
and the other thing this isn't the but i
know it's not the law but if this is if
you accept my my supposition that this
is the public square then it is the law
it is if it is the public square then it
is law now you are arguing it's not the
public square which is fair enough yeah
right that's fine but why don't we move
on because i think we've done enough
yeah yeah he's sucked up a lot of us
he's got to have that he's doing that no
but i'll just say just finally i i do
again
it's like a coin toss for me the hunter
biden laptop thing because i i do
understand how
corrosive it is
for
an institution like the the new york
times
to show obvious bias and inconsistency
and
dishonesty in how they because like they
couldn't even frame it honestly it's not
like
it's not like it's like the way i would
frame it is
uh
listen i don't care what's in hunter
biden's i mean a hunter bite at that
point hunter bind literally could have
had had the corpses of children in his
basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
hunter biden right it's not it's like
it's not joe biden but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if you if
we could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right i mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against trump
university right trump university as a
story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop in my view
right
now that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
left-wing conspiracy to deny the
presidency to donald trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but i
think it was warranted right and i'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not sam i'm sorry that particular piece
i'm really sorry i i was the one that
said we should move on but you've just
said something i really struggled with
that which is
no no [ __ ] the kids in the basement i'm
interested in democracy you're saying
you are content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not left
wing right so liz cheney is not left
wing right liz cheney is doing
everything in her pocket to prevent
somebody being democratic it's not like
no but there's nothing conspiracy it's
not it was a conspiracy out in the open
it does but it doesn't matter if it was
it doesn't matter what parts conspiracy
what part's out in the open i mean i
think it's like
if people get together and talk and talk
about what should we do about this
phenomenon you know if it's like if
there was an asteroid hurtling toward
earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy you know like some
of that conversation would be in public
some of it would be in private
we have a massive problem we have an
existential threat right politically
speaking i consider trump an existential
threat to our democracy right now he's
not going to destroy the world
very likely he destroyed democracy in
the process of protecting democracy but
that doesn't destroy no
you are are
i'm not what i'm not suggesting at no
point was i suggesting we should stuff
ballots or
or actually break the machinery of
democracy but
the
all
political opinion is already being
just completely inundated with
misinformation bias takes half truths
and outright lies right like and or just
the amplification of bad or misleading
information based on you know the
algorithm right
um
so it's like it's already
just an abattoir
of opinion right and
now the question is
you know what can you do with your own
biases and your own the the to to get
the outcome you think is actually better
not just for yourself personally but for
the world right so like i have like
it is i'm completely unconflicted in
in
the claim
that a tr that is a first trump term was
bad and a second trump term would be bad
and
it literally doesn't matter what was
what what else was on the menu like
literally pick a pick a random american
better than trump in the in the oval
office like the the likelihood that
you're going to get someone who's worse
than trump
given what i consider that
is bad about trump
is
i mean it's
it's on the order of one in a million
right like you're just not you're not
going to get you're not going to get
worse than trump if you pick at random
and you know hillary clinton for all of
her flaws was not worse than trump joe
biden joe biden we could have known joe
biden was going to just be comatose in
office
not worse than trump right um kamala
hair is not worth it like like it's all
and and again it's not just a
marginal call it's just
these are people who are
normal politicians who are so much more
constrained by predictable
machinery
right there's there's like there's
there's such less
of an opportunity there to
[Music]
destroy institutions that we have to
rely on right if with any of those
people in charge including a random
person in charge a random person who's
going to be terrified at the
responsibility of the office and default
to expert opinion
you know across the board
no trump is again a trump is an alex
jones level figure for me and okay and
so you know it's it's analogy like a
smaller problem is to just for some
billionaire to buy the new york times
and give it to alex jones to run right
that would be an enormous catastrophic
loss and mistake but that's a smaller
problem than getting trump reelected
hey francis do you like journalism of
course so who's your favorite journalist
then superman what superman superman
isn't a real person francis he's an
alien he's not a journalist and more
importantly he's [ __ ] fictional mate
if he was fictional then why did
frederick nature write about superman
otherwise known as ubermensch in his
seminal work thus spoke zarathustra
published in 1883 but still widely
quoted today by both students and
intellectuals alike
sometimes francis i feel as if i have no
clue who you really are but if you do
like journalism then you have to check
out the epoch times the epoch times
unlike most media organizations is
produced without the influence of any
government corporation or political
party they distill a story down to the
fact and get readers as close to the
truth as they can the articles are free
from the influence of big tech corporate
media and socialist and communist forces
as well the epoch times believe the more
facts you have at your disposal the
better able you are to preserve your
rights here's what the readers say about
them the articles present a factual
picture of the news from a conservative
and american perspective i feel the
epoch times is the only publication out
there that gives me factual information
about stories in the news that other
outlets and publications blatantly
report with liberal political biases go
to epoch t i m e s forward slash
trigonometry and click the link that's
epoch tim e p o c h t i m dot e s slash
trigonometry
the last question i'm gonna ask which
actually isn't really about trump is
i think could you agree that
with trump the reason he is created is
because he is a symptom of the system
whereby people ordinary people feel that
their voices aren't being heard yeah
they realize that you know washington is
a machine that doesn't particularly care
about
about them they were betrayed time after
time many times by the democrats many
times by the democrats who said that
they were representing ordinary working
people like the labour party were in my
country
and they felt that these politicians
didn't care so why not vote for trump
what else have you got to lose yeah oh
yeah no i think that
explains
most of the his support and certainly
his success yeah but but i think i think
we should be
honest about how
um
well both uninformed and nihilistic by
turns that
attitude is right it's just like it's
not
i mean that that is like the
the clearest eruption of thanatos you
know in our lifetime right it's just
like let's
let's just burn it all down on some
level like he this guy's our wrecking
ball
we hate the elites we hate the so-called
experts go [ __ ] yourselves we're just
gonna enjoy just watching this thing you
know you know swing through everything
you care about
and and uh
you know just
the sounds of explosions are gonna just
give us pleasure right like that like
that's where we are
with tens of millions of people in this
country
that's a very you know that is a
a very scary basis from which to try to
uh you know cooperate at scale and and
um
produce political outcomes that are
actually going to be good right and and
again the extremes amplify each other
right so you've got trumpism i mean not
there was no greater goad to woke-ism
than trumpism right and so like and you
know i
i put myself you know in second place
to nobody uh
you know although
i probably spent a little bit less time
on it than than some people we could
name
in my
in the revulsion i feel to
the the extreme left
you know activism right i mean it's just
it's it's as dishonest as it can
possibly be
um
and it's
and it's dishonesty it's harder to parse
for smart people smart ethical people
find what's happening on the left much
more confusing than what's happening on
the right so it's like so people ask me
like and so and i spend much more time
focused on the left than i than i do on
trump or on the right
because not in this interview
you've got the full dose of my trump
revulsion is a strong word
why do and i feel exactly the same thing
and you know why we talked about my book
before i come from a society that's seen
some of these ideas being implemented
why do you
feel revulsion a very very strong
emotion about this ideology
well because it's um
i mean one it is destroying institutions
that i actually care about right so like
you know white supremacy
and far right
lunacy is not affecting
institutions that matter
you know
by my lights right
you know you could argue it it affected
the you know the white house and then
the us government to some degree at the
margins i mean i i think
i think um
allegations of trump's racism or his
alignment with
the far far right and white supremacist
i think that's been massively
exaggerated by the left and you know
most of
most of the claims to his right i have i
actually have no doubt that he's
actually racist but most of the public
claims to his racism i think are
obviously false and and you know
inconsistent and
um so it's uh i mean i think you have to
be intellectually honest even as you
derive these dangerous uh people and
extremes
um so
uh
the le so the the left has
you know as i'm sure you've pointed out
many times on on your show i mean it has
it has captured institutions it has
captured academia it's captured
journalism it's captured science to an
amazing degree it's captured
hollywood it's um
and for reasons that are understandable
because you know it is hard to figure
out what's wrong with black lives matter
as as a movement as it's like it's
you you look at it you know for it it's
it's almost perfectly
engineered to
just you know get past the the
the blood brain barrier and just
attach to all the right ethical receptor
sites right it's like it's just this is
this is uh
of course i care about
you know
of course racism is is
disgusting
i would the last thing i would want to
be as a racist of course i acknowledge
the the legacy of slavery and and just
how hard-fought all of our civil rights
gains have been in the united states
of course i don't want you to
members of minority groups feeling
victimized you know much less being
victimized
uh you know i want fair hiring practices
i would just just check all the boxes on
on you know
to have a good liberal conscience right
if you're that sort of person and you
you're confronted by the black lives
matter as a social phenomenon and the
protest over george floyd and all of
that
it is very hard to see
that you're in the presence of a
completely dishonest
moral panic
right because there's so many points of
contact with real grievance or potential
points of contact with real grievance
and um
so yeah it's it's uh
it's harder to parse therefore more
interesting
and it's also more consequential in my
world because it's vitiating the new
york times and
princeton university and
you know science magazine and it's like
it's just
it's um
it's a it's a full-on moral panic out
there and and what's more you have this
layer of smart people who think all of
that's being exaggerated right it's not
really happening it's just a few college
campuses a few kids you know on a few
college campuses it's just like you know
18 people at yale you know
land based in
uh nicholas christakis
and
everyone else is really just a bystander
to this and it's it's um
it's all being exaggerated
the kernel of truth there is it really
is it's still a minority of people who
actually believe this stuff but you know
you only need something like five or
eight percent of you know really
energized
uh activist minority to
completely co-opt a conversation and
that's what has been accomplished and
but it's not just they're a minority
they're an exceptionally powerful
minority sound oh yeah you know they're
the ones who dictate culture they're the
ones who set the tone they're the ones
who you know who edit and create
newspapers 100
so that's the real problem isn't it but
the question that i want to ask you is
where do you think this is going to go
where do you think this is going to end
up because he's more positive about it
and i'm a rabid pessimist right where do
you think this is going to go
well i think
if i had to bet i think
the vapors of
wokism will magically dissipate at a
certain point i think i think it's just
whether we're going to have
one example of
hypocrisy or um
you know just one own goal that is so
spectacular that everyone will just
all of a sudden pretend that they were
never woke you know like whether it's
going to be that this is going to be a
salient moment where you can you can
point to in your timeline or it's just
going to be this magical dissipation of
you know where people start making much
more sense on these topics
i if i had to bet i would think that's
going to happen
and i don't think it's good so i and i
think it's going to happen in some short
order i don't think
we're going to be having this
conversation in
five years i would i would be very
surprised if we're having this
conversation in five years now that you
know count me i guess as an optimist on
that front
um and i certainly could be wrong but
i would be surprised um
i mean the one caveat i would i would
put there is
if we get four more years of trump then
that goes completely out the window and
i think or if we get four more years of
trump or a trump-like phenomenon that's
just as provocative to the left
then then that calculation changes but
if we got an if we've got a normal
presidency in 2024 you know democrat or
republican
um
i think the woke thing has just become
so
unpragmatic
and
um
yeah i just i just don't i don't see how
people don't
begin aging out of it
in some short order i mean it's somewhat
analogous to the
it's a much bigger phenomenon but it is
analogous to the
the child sexual abuse satanic panic
thing we had and i don't know if you
guys had it in england no we just had
the catholic church
yeah which is the tree yeah which is the
true version of many of these concerns
yeah um
but uh
yeah i mean in the states i don't know
if you know the story that um
uh the the journalist lawrence wright uh
told on my podcast uh but he he wrote a
book on on this and uh when he was doing
a the new yorker article that became a
book he was so he was just re
researching the whole satanic panic
phenomenon and this is in the 80s in the
states
and so the allies of the for those who
are too young to have to remember this i
mean the allegation was that you know
satanic cults that infiltrated
preschools and they just in a very you
know uh
conspiratorial way had decided to just
get access to kids so that they could
perform human sacrifices and
ritual abuse and this was now happening
at scale in american society and
you know we had this massive problem and
it was
you know who knows what was
uh you know truly at the bottom of it
and you know whether it's a
certain rock lyrics we're getting into
the heads of teenagers and spawning a uh
a generation of devil worshipers you
know who could who could tell but we
clearly have a problem on our hands
and so lawrence wright uh in kind of
getting on board to this phenomenon
went to a seminar
run by
law enforcement i think i'm not sure if
it wasn't it might have been in texas um
where he's lived for many years um
so just this is you know a seminar for
you know journalists run by law
enforcement
and he remembers that moment where
the the sheriff or
some uh
leo um
said to the group
last year
50 000 children
were murdered
in ritual sacrifices by satanic cults in
this country right this is a cop saying
this and it took lawrence you know five
seconds to
understand that there's been no year in
american history where there have been
50 000 murders of any kind right and yet
here we have a cop
saying
that that uh 50 000 kids have been
killed there's 50 000 missing you know
and murdered kids right um
so
what explains that level of confusion
and derangement right like so we're in a
moment like that and here's the question
we were going to ask you about that and
i'm really glad you phrased it in that
way sam because i was a big fan of the
new atheist movement no francis and i
and not none none of the three of us are
religious right i was a big admirer and
i still am a big admirer of yours
richard dawkins i read many of his books
um
however
is it possible
just is it possible that people like us
who think in the way that we do
have forgotten that thing i think it was
it chesterton who said this that when
you stop believing god you don't believe
in nothing you believe in anything right
is it possible that this new religion
and i certainly see workness as a
religion
is a product of a society that has let
go of that a religion that he used to
follow
well i think it's
the short answer is probably not because
i think many of the woke are
you know religious by my lights i mean
they would certainly claim to be
religious it's not like you have a i
mean i don't know if pauline research
exists on this would be interesting to
run these polls but
yes yes
loss of faith has been
kind of ramping up in in america and you
know really in all
secular democracies um
but it's still not you know you don't
have a minority of people you don't have
a majority of people identified as
atheists right and this and the minority
that identify with atheists is still
still in a single digits because because
atheism as a concept is just has got bad
you know pr associated with it um you
have something like 20 to 25 percent of
the so-called nuns who are again these
are not people who identify as atheists
but these are people who would say
they're not identified with any specific
church but you still have most people
who are you know at least nominally
christian and and pretend to care about
being christian
you know in the u.s at this moment and
you have something like
fully half who are you know
real really will check many or more you
know all the boxes to to attest to their
belief um
it's more than how you know it's
if you ask if you uh
and so and again a lot of these people
are on the christian right but many of
them are
are awoke or awoke adjacent you know
it's like i just
was on van jones podcast right now he's
not
i mean he's much woker than either
any of us um i think he's probably said
some
rational pragmatic things we didn't
actually talk about i remember seeing
some of that he's just kind of taken the
obama line of like like you saying
listen kids like this is not you know
they're bigger problems than
pronouns or whatever i don't know how he
touched it but
um
but still he's like
if he's someone who's coverage of black
lives matter
i would have you know
many critical things to say about it and
and um uh
again the topic didn't come up but he's
you know he's someone who if you ask him
do you think jesus will be returning to
earth to
raise the living and the dead
i am pretty sure he would say yes
right and and you'd be surprised at the
number at the number of
the percentage of sober
non-bible-thumping people
would say yes to that question i mean i
was i've been
amazed at like the people who i who i
would have
that a lot of money would be i would be
skeptical of that piece they would they
they might be
christian they might be like listen i
love the bible it gives me a great moral
framework it gives my kids a great moral
framework of the tradition
this is the this is the tradition i'm
identified with this is all super
important to me
um
but that's kind of as far as it goes
right like i'm not going to make the
magical claims about flying saviors who
are literally going to come down from
where where is heaven exactly given that
we have
you know
multiple
telescopes up there you know beaming
back you know
tens of billions of years worth of
information
um
i'm amazed at the number of people who
will bite the bullet on the core
doctrine and say yeah i think jesus is
going to come back and raise
the dead right but so i'm surely you
have to agree in a society which is
becoming ever more atomized let me just
let me just close the loop
many of these people are awoke right so
you can't say you can't the punchline
can't be well they lost their religion
and now they're there there's they have
a vacuum of an ethical and
and um
existential vacuum that they're filling
with wokeness now there's i i would
grant you that it's and
don't lose your point i would grant you
that it's drawing
a lot of
quasi-spiritual quasi-religious energy
from
the fact that
most people
in our society
even if they're nominally religious
really are are struggling to to find
meaning in in their day in their day to
day but when you look at just the kind
of the
the hour by hour increments at which you
know life has doled out to us
like you get up and you know you just
you're you're
cast out of you know
deep sleep or you know the
phantasmagoria of dreams
you know when the alarm goes off in the
morning and
how do you feel about your life and what
is going to give you
moral urgency and meaning
a lot of
millions and millions of people found
it at specific moments in our you know
recent history like and you know the
george floyd
killing was certainly one of those
moments where it's like okay this is
enough is enough like this is my
religion right
and and that's um
it's understandable and it is yes it
does have a religious dynamic
uh
and there's a religious dynamic i mean
to call it religious
is to just basically say
it's actually an invidious statement
about religion it's basically like all
the things i don't like about religion
is tribalism it's dogmatism it's
it's immunity to good arguments and good
evidence right the fact that just it
can't be reasoned with really because
it's just chucked reason out the door
you know initially or when and what it's
brought back in the name of reason is
functioning under the
the
the sort of the new physics of just
casualty like like we already know that
god exists and we know that the bible is
perfect we know the quran is perfect and
so within that frame
now we're going to get really reasonable
like you know st thomas aquinas or um
uh saint augustine uh
that's all the stuff about relig
that religion that i find
uh so obviously wrong and it's so easy
to see once you're not indoctrinated
into that religion
a lot of that
is explains what is happening
politically with on the far left and the
far right at the moment or you know the
far right being a trumpet
right uh so sam but you
i think all of us have got to admit that
in a society we're becoming ever more
atomized where people are becoming more
isolated
religion organized religion
it was a bond it was a community people
could go they could meet other people
they could feel connected and so when
people are disconnected they're going to
look for ways to connect with someone
else and what better way to do that was
then with you know i support this
political movement blm or you know
you share the same immutable
characteristics as me you know i'm gay
or i'm black or et cetera et cetera and
because we're so desperate because we're
literally programmed to form communities
that we're going to have this ideology
which is going to enable us to create a
community
yeah and and
on the woke side it has this
i mean it has a precursor in
christianity but it's it's um
somehow in a pure form now it has
inverted the the
value structure such that
you know
the lower status you are the higher
status you you come out you know once
the calculation has been done it's like
you know dungeons and dragons with the
sort of the new dice whereas like the
the least power points you have
you know you you know the more you find
yourself winning and so the victimology
of it is um
you know and the and the meek shall
inherit the earth i mean it's really it
is that
ethos um implemented in a very weird way
um and sort of gamified somehow uh in
all of the intersectionality details of
it um
yeah i mean it's
there's no question people
draw a tremendous amount of energy and
you know i hesitate to say meaning i
mean there's a meaning and scare quotes
from
this and it's all i mean i guess so i
mean to steal man
all of it you know briefly maybe it is
again it's especially on the left
it's genuinely confusing right like like
the the the
the mad work that the tiny pieces of
misinformation or or just
fraudulent assumptions
is doing
is
um it's really impossible to exaggerate
if you ask most people who like most
people who saw the george floyd
moment i mean it's um
again i i don't know it's
we've yet to totally understand what
happened there because like you know who
knows
just let's bracket that because i don't
we still don't know who derek shoving
really is and why he did what he did
right so like either it was a racist
murder or it was a
you know his brain malfunctioned or like
i just i don't i honestly i look at that
video i don't know what i'm looking at
there it's just a it's a
apart from the the horrible uh killing
of a person who certainly did not need
to be killed in that situation
um
but you ask most most people who saw
that
the vast majority of people who saw that
you know certainly left of center
would bet their lives but the lives of
their children that what they saw there
was a a racist lynching right like that
was a we have what we have is a white
man killing a black man
because of racism because like that
wouldn't have happened to a white man it
wouldn't have been perpetrated by a
black man race is a hundred percent of
the explanatory variable there
um
and
not only was that as
unambiguously evil
and sadistic and racist
as it seemed
that happens
thousands of times a year in america
like you ask people to estimate how many
how many black people do you think get
murdered by white racist cops in america
every year
they imagine we're talking thousands
right so if you believe that
right then what
would you do
you know what would you wouldn't you two
take to the streets when
when everyone says we're going to you
know we're we're protesting uh on
tuesday
of course right so it's like so you
don't have to add too many pieces of uh
you know distorting you know
uh
pseudofacts
to get to get
people who i otherwise totally
understand
to
mouth you know
you know all the the predictable pieties
on this topic
but the truth is
all of that is wrong right like you know
it's you can count on on two hands the
number of unarmed
black men
who get killed every year by cops
um
and you can count more white people who
get killed every year by cops right
under identical circumstances uh again
i've talked about this in my podcast so
we need not go there those who are
interested could look at um
the episode can we pull back from the
brink it was beautiful yeah like two
hours i talked about it was exactly what
needed to be said in that moment right i
really congratulate you on that i invite
people to go and find that really very
good yeah so we can leave that aside but
the mis so the the misinformation or the
faulty assumptions
occur at the highest level right it's
like this is not you know i mean does
i guess there's some people who actually
know what is real here
and are just cynically manipulating the
politics but i mean it's hard for me to
believe that
someone like kamala harris doesn't
actually know the numbers right but
um
it's not in her political interests or
in what she conceives of as her
political interests to
act like she knows the numbers right
um
but anyway it's so it's it's not i mean
the charitable view is
there there are very few people who are
consciously
[Music]
lying
um
or seeking to
[Music]
do things that they know are wrong i
mean just conscious evil is a rare thing
yes and
i mostly use fully dates it's what i
talk about in my book yes i agree with
you
hey constantin do you want better mental
health i'm from russia we don't have
mental health so how do you deal with
mental health you drink vodka then go
out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the bear's feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my adhd
and become better in all areas of my
life
why is he telling them how weak he is
drink vodka feel better better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
forward slash trigger especially if
they're not real men that's b e t t e r
h e l p dot com slash trigger
sam listen you've been very generous
with the time there's about 50 other
questions we want to ask you we're not
going to get a chance to uh so we'll
pick out from our we do a couple of
questions for our supporters so i'll
make sure to pick out a covered question
because that's that came up a lot okay
um there was before we ask you the final
question if you don't mind uh a few more
minutes
um i wanted well francis and i both
wanted actually to ask you we've talked
about these very divisive things and
people will have a different opinion
about trump and covid and brexit and all
of this stuff whatever you want to look
but one thing that it strikes me is
you're
one of the few people that we've met who
is content
who's happy i can tell right
how does
how if people are watching this and they
would like to be happy in spite of all
the terrible things that they think
about they see happening on twitter
it strikes me francis uses your app
every morning
how do
you how does one in the modern world
get closer to that point where
whatever is happening out whatever
storms are out there you are calm and
peaceful inside
well first let me say i'm not i'm
certainly not always calm and peaceful
but the
your half-life is great yeah yeah
um
but the truth is
so i mean the back story here is that
you know in my early 20s i got really
into meditation and
i mean the first psychedelics just
showed me that it was possible to have a
very different experience of the world
and
uh and that there was a landscape of
mind that could be explored
based on just how you paid attention to
experience right so i i prior to
psychedelics i would have
really just been kind of waiting for the
third person brain-based discussion to
deliver you know all the right answers
about you know what the human mind is
and it was it was pretty
well established and still is you know
thought to be well established in
western science in psychological science
cognitive science and even even
western philosophy
that introspection was a dead end i mean
they tried to get it off the ground
somewhere around 120 years ago
and it just you know you
you come up short almost immediately i
mean the truth is you can't you close
your eyes and you look inside
and you can't even tell that you have a
brain right much less that the brain is
doing all of these complex things that
is actually delivering your experience
of the world so
um
and
i mean this is just one curious
asymmetry of you know cultural wisdom
in the east you know
for all the failings of what didn't
happen civilizationally in in eastern
culture
uh
and there's a lot to be said about that
um
they didn't lose this strand of wisdom
which is there actually is something to
be discovered in a first person way
about the nature of your own mind that
is liberating right like that you you
suffer by a certain
um
machinery a certain dynamics
which you which could be either
completely inscrutable to you or can
become more and more
transparent and and in its transparency
less and less operative on a you know a
moment by moment basis and so
i mean take any of the topics we've
talked about so we we've talked about me
getting on twitter and getting really
spun up over you know somebody saying
something about me or about something
else that i care about
um
you know i've talked about anyone who
thinks i have trump derangement syndrome
is going to look at me and say well you
why are you talking to this guy about
meditation this guy's so worked up over
trump you know what it is like this is a
you know it's a performative
contradiction right
um that's actually to
misunderstand my
you know emotional relationship to the
phenomenon of trump right like
i can say everything
i say about and think about trump
without spending much time
feeling contracted around trump i mean
but it's not to say that's not to say no
time but it's just much less time than i
otherwise would if i didn't know how to
to you know quote meditate right now the
word meditation can mean many different
things
to people but
what i think it should mean is
a
just a simple recognition of
what consciousness is like
prior to entanglement with thought right
so we're all
three of us are sitting here
and
we're having a
an experience of the world that's
happening in you know five sensory
channels
but there's this there's this other
mode or this other you know
aspect to our condition which is
our thinking about what we directly
experience through our senses right and
the for for most people most of the time
the thoughts are
incessant
and uninspected right and and their
arising is unnoticed right so you're
just it just feels like you
right it's like so you'll say something
that i disagree with and
that there's a voice in me which says
what's he talking about or like what
does that mean or like what like about
what he did but you just
like there's just that voice that you
know is
that either feels like a self i mean in
you know nearly 100 of
the cases
that just feels like i right that feels
like
it's me and
then you're you're told something about
the project of
well again you see you could have an
experience
haphazardly or on psychedelics where
that get that identification gets
interrupted right where all of a sudden
there's ju the mind is suddenly much
more vast than that right it doesn't
feel like there's a subject in the head
looking out through your eyes at a world
that's not you
and
you know forever implicated by the
glances of other people and the opinions
of other people and it's just me and
here this sort of embattled ego
trying to
navigate a world that is you know
fundamentally or at least potentially
hostile to my interests right like that
subject object dichotomy where it's just
like i'm the man in the boat trying to
steer it you know
to some safe place
and not go over the falls emotionally
that suddenly relaxes
again it matters now i guess i'm talking
about psychedelics because it's it's
more more uh replicatable for people
depending on what drug you've taken that
can relax in one or another way i mean
mdma is really just the relaxing of the
the emotional tone of all that without
the the
the pyrotechnics of
of changing your perceptions
if it's lsd or psilocybin you can have a
real much more fundamental
transformation of how you perceive the
world but whatever is the case
it just so happens that our nervous
systems are perturbable
pharmacologically or just by
happenstance right this could happen to
you just because it happens to you right
um and people have those stories
but
there's vast testimony on this topic
that you can you can
experience your mind
as a much vaster place than you tend to
experience
it as and
um
and then when you come back from one of
those experiences you might become
interested in what is it that trims it
down so reliably reliably to this
experience of confinement where you feel
like it's just me here feeling uptight
again right you know like what's what's
that about
um
you know virtually a hundred percent of
of that is
just what it's like to be you identified
with thought
and then if you're if you're identified
with thought habitually
you are at the mercy of whatever you
happen to think about right so it's just
like there's a
i never i've
i mean
the analogy i've drawn somewhere is just
it's really it's like
the most boring person in the world
comes through the front door of your
house
and takes you hostage
follows you from room to room telling
you the same stories over and over again
you can't shut him up
and you can't get away from him
and it's just and
that's your life right and you're you're
thinking about the past about what you
could have said or should have said or
almost said you're thinking about the
future what what's this what's you know
how's this going to go and
most of the futures you you visualize
never happen the way you've you've
obsessed about them in the first place
so like 99 of your self-talk
is
i mean at best it's neutral with respect
to its emotional tone i mean that's
really i mean some people have i'm you
know convinced some people have a fairly
happy
self-talk and that's a you know
it's sort of hard to get through to them
because they really don't think of
themselves as ever suffering much
psychologically right they they're very
confident they love the people in their
lives they get a lot of love back
they're not
really conflict they don't have regrets
and disappointments that they're
training they're not you know they're
not worried about anything and they just
want to get up and do it again tomorrow
because they're having so much fun there
are people like that psychopaths
but it's most people are not like that
right most people are are sensitive to
this criticism of the default which is
most of what you're saying to yourself
isn't making you happy
and
worse it's
it's predicated on a fundamental
illusion
of
selfhood of identification with this
this subset of your uh your mental
experience which is this again that this
discursive thought
um and when you break that
identification
there's just much more space there and
the past and and the
and the i mean the the
it is in thought it's an identification
with thought that the past and the
future
exert their weight on the present right
so like it's like we're
it's because we're
processing everything we experience in
the present
through this scrim of discursive thought
that we don't we never actually make
satisfying contact with the present or
we rarely do and and those moments where
we do
you know those those peak kind of peak
experience moments
what has made it be a peak is breaking
the spell of thought for long enough for
just to let in some of the breeze of you
know awareness that it's always i mean
it's always there
but we just don't you know we're
blocking it continually we just haven't
opened the door or the window
um
and
it's
um so meditation really is again there
are many different techniques or many
different ways to to describe it and
frame it in the end it's actually not
even a practice
you're doing it's not it in the end it
is something you're ceasing to do
it's just
it's non-distraction you're ceasing to
be distracted by thought you're starting
to notice
thoughts themselves as appearances in
consciousness
and noticed as
appearances
they don't have
force they don't have they don't
certainly don't have emotional force
it's not like you suddenly become an
idiot you can't figure out what you want
to eat for dinner or you know how to how
to find your car or i mean you can you
can think and you can plan but
the moment
you you begin to suffer
you become you your your new default is
to become interested in it's like it's
like a mindfulness alarm
you know uh
uh starts sounding
and
then you relax your identification with
it just that just the
the um
the physiology of suffering and so to
bring it back to what we're just talking
about so yeah there's a moment where i
notice something
that
i find
you know either like personally
annoying or or the appropriate target of
moral outrage i i don't think we should
get rea
i'm not envisioning psychological health
as being synonymous with never being
angry ever again or never being
fearful ever again i mean you know
negative emotions
are
you know from from a an enlightened
point of view in my book
are still salience cues right like if i
walk outside this house on the way to my
car and someone physically attacks me on
the sidewalk like i don't want to be
just a puddle of goo you know just
beaming love at the person like that now
it's not it's not to say that there's
not
that's not a possible state of
consciousness it certainly is
and it actually there there are
definitely scenarios where
that that quote works right like just
being the guy who's you know
beaming unconditional love as your only
response to anything
right
it's possible to get out of some
physical altercation because it's just
so surprising right someone comes to mug
you and you're just
you know you're you're on mdma and you
just say listen man
i love you right like that could either
like that could turn out well but
practically speaking
it strikes me as totally appropriate to
feel
these kind of punk tape neg classically
negative emotions
the quit the real question is
how long do they last and what are they
good for like what like when when is it
when do you when do you want to cease
being angry so that you can actually
function intelligently
and in my book
it happens very very soon after the
arising of anger i mean like you don't
you don't want to stay angry right like
but the but the initial
jolt of anger
in in many cases is totally appropriate
and it is the orienting response that
you actually need to respond
intelligently to the you know whatever
the
you know emergency or quasi emergency is
so but
once you know how to meditate
you do notice that the half-life of
negative emotions is really really brief
i mean it's actually impossible to stay
angry
or
embarrassed or
you know whatever it is pick your
negative emotion
for longer than you know
some tens of seconds
unless you then you're taken in by
thought again about why you should be
angry or why you should be embarrassed
and um
yeah your life becomes completely
different when you can get off the ride
you know i mean the difference between
between being angry for 10 seconds
and being angry for 10 minutes even you
know much less 10 hours or 10 days
is enormous right i mean just you just
think of how life deranging
those periods are where you're just
helplessly motivated
by anger
right i mean 10 minutes is enough to
to completely [ __ ] up your life right i
mean to say the thing to your spouse
that you
you can't
to ring the bell you can't un-ring you
know and i mean just like
you just see how people's lives run off
the rails because
their minds are out of control and
literally
everything we see out there
that is producing massive human
suffering and and you know existential
risk even you know like literally
everything beyond
naturally occurring disasters right
is a matter of people's minds being out
of control right we just have we just
we're running
terrible legacy code
you know in a condition of
increasingly
destabilizing
[Music]
power amplified by technology i mean
it's getting increasingly easy
for one person to screw it up for the
rest of us so the topic of existential
risk is its own thing which i've
you know i'm focusing on more and more i
think it's you know it's and it's
you know
neglected to a scary degree i mean it's
just they're just not that they're not
enough people thinking about
how we can shore up our civilization
against existential risk and you know
man-made and otherwise
but
i mean so much of the daily evidence of
conflict and needless human misery is
just born of
people being captured by their thoughts
and not knowing that there's any
alternative right they're just they're
just talking to themselves right and
they're just claiming to know things
that they don't know
and being persuaded by those
those inner proclamations right i mean
just like what does it feel like
to have a very strong opinion
that is going to dictate everything you
do next
and
how often is that just an
automaticity that's totally uninspected
that would be
could be completely deflated
just with another which is a moment's
pause if you only knew how to
you know or just take the other side in
that forget about meditation for a
moment just the ability to
be skeptical about one's own
opinions like that just talk about an
untrained skill i mean that's just
something that
almost nobody has right no nobody even
has it as a possible norm that you could
endorse even in the abstract right like
why would you want to be skeptical about
your own opinions
like this is just what i think
um that's why i'm like you i'm always
starting debates around the dinner table
because i'm always testing what i think
against what other people think and
because i'm aware that it's just thought
and it's refining
but anyway we've got one sam first of
all thank you so much for coming
what a pleasure to see you and speak
with you and get a little bit of your
opinion and wisdom um can i just say if
people are listening to this i use your
app it's actually brilliant and it has
changed my life the ability to just sit
and meditate for 10 minutes every
morning is one of the most if not the
best way to deal with obtrusive and
obsessional thoughts which every time he
comes into the studio and he's
all over the place they go have you
meditated the answer's always no right
yeah so yeah thank you no it's brilliant
and the podcast making sense for sam
harris i'm i'm a big fan of like we
talked about during the blm situation
you covered it i thought exactly the way
that it needed to be covered and you
have important conversations on there uh
we'll do a couple of questions for our
locals i will ask you about covet
because we promised people we'd do that
but before we do our final question is
always the same what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
in this conversation or just anything
as a society um
well we've touched on pieces of it i
mean i do think
that
again at the generic level i mean the
problem is always
failures of cooperation for us at this
point like
virtually anything that's going to just
happen to us you know coughed up by the
hand of nature
we can figure out how to solve at this
point i mean i think i mean including an
asteroid hurtling toward towards us i
mean at this point we have enough tech
and
i'm not so sure we have enough people
watching but
close
that we'll you know we'd have
tens of years right we'd have some
decades to to deal with a problem that
specific problem um
but
so all of our problems on some level of
our are of our own making i mean if
nothing else it's just our
the opportunity costs born of all of the
needless [ __ ] we get entangled with
based on our own you know you know
incapacity to cooperate so it's just
it's um
and that's the first order of business
business and the next one to figure out
how we can
have successful conversations on some
level right like because again all we
have
is
is a capacity to persuade one another
so as to
engineer you know forward-looking
cooperation
or we have violence right like in the
end it's like we just have to force
people to do stuff
if we can't persuade them to do stuff or
that they're you know they they can't
come to the epiphanies on their own
and that's where politics comes in
um
and
but more and more
i think we're in a situation where
because of technology
it's um
it's strangely getting harder and harder
to to get our you know our cognitive
horizons to to fuse right we've got
eight billion
strangers more or less
trying to figure out how to cooperate
and
persuasion is the only
good tool again i mean for i mean we're
gonna have to use force in certain
circumstances and i'm you know and i
think we should be very
i don't think pacifism is is is a plan
there i mean i think we actually do need
to have our force game together for for
the situations where we need it you know
and that's individually and collectively
right at the level of nation states
as well but
i'm yeah i'm increasingly worried about
our incapacity
to converge
on just a dispassionate fact-based
discussion
on things that are just
so easy
to assess i mean just like we've touched
several topics here but just like
how many people of any
identity get killed by cops every year
in america and just like and what are
it's like how does that relate to
the levels of crime you know perpetrated
by people of various identities and like
what situations are cops actually
getting into and what are their
reasonable expectations of people in a
society where there are 400 million guns
you know like why is it different when
an american suddenly turns around and
reaches into the cab of his pickup truck
while getting arrested then when that
happens in japan right like whether
where there are no guns right
this is such a this should be such an
easy conversation to have right there
should be no like like
i mean this is it's not even
i mean it's it's hard to think of a
simpler one where the facts are easier
to get i mean most of the and most of
the stuff is on you know so much of this
stuff is on videotape it's so easy to
parse
um
it's repeatable year after year
it's a problem that everyone like it's
in no one's interest that the problem
be bigger than it is and not smaller
than it is like we want we all want to
solve this problem right
um
and we find it impossible to talk about
so your problem is sam you meditate too
much and you're too smart
you and you think other people are like
you but they're not you know well no but
i i know like there's none of this is
foreign to me i know what it's like to
get emotionally hijacked by any by
something right whether something
happens right in front of you and you're
or you care about ideas about it you
care about the truth and so you will get
emotionally hijacked and then you will
go and look at the facts yeah most
people just get emotionally hijacked
yeah yeah so we i mean we need that is a
uh
i mean certainly a software flaw in our
operating system it's not a feature and
i mean one way i've summarized this in
the past for people is that i mean your
capacity
to be offended
is not something that anyone
need or should respect
in you like that's just not
it's not an argument certainly not an
argument but it's not even a basis for
respect like that like table stakes for
any ethical conversation
is more
than just your capacity to be offended
right and um
until you understand that like you're
just not
you
you can't play the game we need to play
in order to to ensure an open-ended
circumstance of cooperation what a great
note to finish on sam harris thank you
so much for coming on we really
recommend you check out sam's podcast
and his brilliant app we're going to ask
him a couple of questions from you for
you but for now sam thank you so much
for joining us really great to meet you
nice to meet you yeah we'll see you very
soon with another brilliant episode i
mean it won't be quite like this but it
will be a brilliant episode as well or
raw show all of them go out at 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
some of our listeners would be
disappointed in how you handled yourself
during cohort
um
how do you reflect on the way
you
thought and spoke about covet are you
happy with it would you have done it
differently
[Music]